chaque être masculin à dans un coin de
son coeur ou de son imagination il
photographie physique et morale ce qu'on
peut appeler la femme idéale appartion
fait de moi ce qui confère au nomadisme
tous les supports par avons à disputer
un seul instant en dessous via veut rien
ou presque elle était simplement vêtue
d'un ravissant et minuscule bikini bleu
à pois blancs mais bien entendu les
amoureux sont toujours follement là vous
avez une femme bien oui j elle s'est
plaint pas vous savez les très
compréhensive s'intéresse absolument à
tout ce que je fais
ça me ferait quoi vous d'être peut-être
le dernier homme sur terre un robinson
avec le monde entier comme île déserte
ça ça nous a toujours angoissé et quand
je dis nous on va pas se mentir c'est
tout spécialement les hommes justement
si la fin du monde c'était un jugement
dernier on pourrait se dire que c'est un
genre de retour aux sources avec ce
pauvre type tout seul au jardin d'éden
et comme il supportait déjà pas soi
disant dieu créa la femme pas pour
elle-même donc mais bien pour monsieur
et pour celle d'harnes celles dont les
approuver une énergie plus qu'à chaque
fois que monsieur se retrouver isolé une
disons en prison ou au front il lui
fallait absolument une dame même sur
papier glacé
les pin up comme on disait c'était
littéralement en bon anglais des femmes
que l'on pouvait punaisée au mur pour
nous tenir compagnie parfois elle se
déplacer en personne pour venir soutenir
les gars mais faute des vents chair et
en os elle venait peuple et les murs des
vestiaires ou des chambres d'ados
outre le fait d'être un fantasme
masculin le point commun entre une
ferrari et lolo ferrari ne saute pas
forcément aux yeux des effigies comme
autant de statut modeler non pas à
partir des côtes de monsieur mais de ds
alors venez re est une drôle de façon
hélas ce n'est pas une chanson c'est
bien ferrer qui revendique sa misogynie
pour aimer les femmes m misogyne savoir
mettre les femmes à leur place sur une
trône ça les adorer mais quand on a fini
les adorer il faut que tu es certain que
ça tous les cas les femmes cultivées
pas pour leurs puissants sous leur
autorité puis quoi encore
non pour leur beauté leur plastique et
leurs sourires entendus
bref des attributs qu'une simple image
suffisait à retranscrire enfin ou quoi
que parce qu'à bien y regarder l'homme
livré à lui même ne se retrouvait pas
embarrassé que par la solitude et l'aft
il de temps en temps la vaisselle jamais
pour bien raison parce qu'ils sont pas
mon rôle
quel est votre rôle alors certes
monsieur mais les icônes dévêtue mais
pas de ça chez lui ou tout au plus
planquer sous un matelas les portes d'un
lieu caché ou l'ombre d'un lointain
périphériques de la femme au foyer elle
devait être de bonnes manières
en fait la pin up des origines ça
résumait assez bien ce paradoxe des airs
innocents comme inconscients de leur
charme leur côté gaffeur mêlant quelques
attributs mais par inadvertance une
ambiguïté qui convenait parfaitement aux
messieurs dames élevé
après tout qui le mieux placé pour
savoir ce qui était acceptable chez une
dame nous auriez pas trop vous mettre
ainsi sur la sellette et on on peut se
donner la parole simplement à des hommes
voulant reprendre et très riche avec en
plus un actif peut être un acquis le
fait de savoir ce qu'il faut faire ou ce
que vous pouvez faire pour nous plaire
encore plus avec l'arrivée de la boîte à
images les femmes sur les posters
pourrait s'animer
seulement voilà attention au scandale
parce que le problème avec la télé c'est
que c'est vachement plus dur à planquer
qu'un magazine elle trônait là au beau
milieu du salon familial et pendant un
moment on n'avait pas trop le choix des
chaînes il avait suffi de quelques
secondes d'un galbe qui en un lieu où on
se devait moins de faire bonne figure
n'aurait choqué personne pour provoquer
la création du célèbre carré blanc qui
est en fait un rectangle blanc les
speakerines c'était un peu les femmes au
foyer de l'ovaire tf alors elle se
devait d'être présentable au point que
lorsque l'une d'elles s'aventure à
apporter une jupe
la voilà aussitôt congédié pour
préserver les bonnes moeurs
à moins que cela est élu à voir avec les
avances du directeur de l'information
qu'elle aurait eu le mauvais goût de
repousser
renvoyé pour en avoir trop montrer en
public
ou peut-être pas assez en privé
décidément c'est toujours le même
problème avec ces messieurs
alors vont dire et pourtant la télé ne
jurait que par une certaine ménagères de
moins de cinquante ans en fait surtout
l'image que s'en faisait ceux qui
voulaient bien parler à sa place
ménagère elle veut avoir un aspirateur
d'avoir infligé des elmes avoir une
machine à laver la ménagère vue progrès
mais je pars la pagaille la
libéralisation à la fois des moeurs et
des canaux et retient mis fin au
problème dans ce nouveau raz-de-marée
d'image il pouvait retrouver ses nains
favorite peuplant le plateau de quelques
satire de son genre si ces femmes de
l'écran n'avait pas forcément gagner en
galons par rapport aux speakerine l avc
/ perdu quelques vêtements
mais si les hommes faisait tous ça c'est
parce qu'ils aiment et les femmes non à
tel point que les hommes qui n'aimaient
pas les femmes
c'était suspect était très très
distinguée
ray distingue énormément distingue les
gens disent et n'ont pas tous le même ça
ne devrait pas être permis ça ça
n'aurait pas permis
il aurait tout fait pour elle enfin
quand même pas leur laisser recevoir
leurs propres salaires ou le droit de
vote où l'égalité salariale fois tu
oublies mettre la main sur professeur wu
yulu c'est le meilleur spécialiste de la
question n'aurait jeanne le professeur
vous nous vous le trouvez vous l'amenez
kido qui est capable de vous dire ce que
veulent les femmes c'est que pendant
tout ce temps il s'était passé quelque
chose eh bien il aura fallu tout ce
temps presqu'un an pour qu'enfin
paraissent une femme dans notre mission
sans doute nous les producteurs de armes
égales sommes nous nous aussi victime
des préjugés qui selon certains
constituent et d'anciens en france la
colonisation de la femme est comme ça on
a vu apparaître petit à petit des images
nouvelles de femmes dans des lieux où on
les voyait auparavant presque jamais
tout ce qu'on l'a refusée elle avait
pris d'elle même les pin-ups décroché du
mur alors il fallait vite les re cloué
au pilori si nécessaire mais en vain ce
qu'est un temps paraissait un signe de
l'apocalypse elle en avait fait une
évidence et ainsi on retrouvait des
pin-up autrefois silencieuse qui
chantait désormais le girl power
sous les yeux de pygmalion sidéré et
certainement madame
seront reconnus
cela vous donnera assurances et
autorités dans la ville
mais madame on habille vous tellement
besoin et pour chaque avancée il fallait
rejouer le match
encore et encore à regarder en arrière
on se rend compte que certains croyaient
qu abandonner leurs privilèges ce serait
la fin du monde et je peux pas
m'empêcher de penser
est-ce qu'on en serait là si on avait
dépensé autant d'énergie à combattre les
catastrophes qui nous ont vraiment mener
à notre faim est-ce qu'on se sera battu
jusqu'au bout pour rester le roi et se
retrouver comme ça
roi du tas de cendres peut-être qu être
le dernier homme sur terre sans
angoisser - les femmes je sais pas
peut-être parce que le monde d'avant
leur manquerait pas autant que nous bien
sûr les cousins of law 10 à l'idée que
l'égalité des sexes et je dois l'avouer
par la force de la couture fait juger
les hommes ont l'air de déplaire
[Musique]